>> Sean: THANK YOU BOTH.
PETE HEGSETH,
DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA.
THE OTHER RADICAL 2020
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE, MARIANNE
WILLIAMSON, SHE'S UNDER FIRE AND
UNDER ATTACK FROM OTHER
DEMOCRATS AND SHE HAS SUDDENLY
COME TO THE REALIZATION THAT THE
LEFT IN AMERICA IS MEAN.
WE BEEN POINTING THIS OUT MANY
TIMES ON THE SHOW.
THE LEFT ACTS LIKE IT HAS A
MONOPOLY ON COMPASSION.
EVERY DAY UNLEASHING AN ENDLESS
STREAM OF VICIOUS, VILE
COMMENTS.
THEY GET AWAY WITH IT.
BIG DOUBLE STANDARD AND LOOK AT
HOLLYWOOD FOR EXAMPLE.
WASHED UP ACORD JIM CARREY IS
ACCUSING MITCH McCONNELL BEING
WORSE THAN BIN LADEN.
THAT COMES AFTER ACTRESS DEBRA
MESSING WANTED TO BLACKLIST ALL
TRUMP SUPPORTERS IN HOLLYWOOD,
NAMING ALL THE DONORS.
WITH REACTION, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR DON MANGINO,
FOX NEWS CORRESPONDENT AT LARGE
GERALDO RIVERA.
ARE YOU, HAVE YOU EVER BEEN,
DAN BONGINO, A SUPPORTER OF
DONALD TRUMP?
A SMELLY WALMART SHOPPER LIKE
HANNITY.
ARE YOU AN IRREDEEMABLE
DEPLORABLE?
I HUMBLY CLING TO MY GUNS FOR
PROTECTION.
I BELIEVE IN THE BIBLE AND MY
RELIGION AND MY FAITH.
GUILTY ON ALL COUNTS.
>> MARIANNE WILLIAMSON, I DON'T
KNOW WHERE SHE'S BEEN.
HAVING RUN FOR OFFICE, I AM
FAMILIAR WITH THE ATROCIOUS LEFT
AND HOW THEY TREAT
CONSERVATIVES.
I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE BUT IT'S
WORTH THE AUDIENCE TUNING IN.
WE THINK LIBERALS ARE PEOPLE
WITH REALLY BAD IDEAS.
BUT LIBERALS DON'T THINK THE
SAME OF US.
THEY THINK WE ARE BAD PEOPLE
WITH IDEAS.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE.
THAT'S WHAT BRINGS OUT THIS
VITRIOL.
I THINK WHY TRUMP, THE
RIDICULOUS TWEETS BY JIM CARREY.
DEBRA MESSING, I DON'T REMEMBER
THE OTHER GUY.
THEY WANT TO BLACKLIST -- ERIC
McCORMACK.
THEY WANT TO BLACKLIST.
THIS IS REAL AND THIS THING
GOING ON FOR DECADES MAGES
REALLY, REALLY DISLIKE -- TRUMP
WON'T BACK DOWN AND THAT
INFURIATES THEM EVEN MORE.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, HE DID
WIN ON THE WALL.
I SAID HE'S CHANGING STRATEGIES,
NOT GIVING UP.
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 500
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 50M
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 50L
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 50S
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 50H
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 50T
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 50W
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 50L
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 50B
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 50I
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 50T
NOW HE'S PROMISING, HE WANTS 50.
3.6 BILLION, REALLOCATED AS HE
PROMISED HE WOULD GET DONE.
OVERALL, HOW DO YOU ASSESS THESE
CLIMATE CHANGE FANATICS?
>> I THINK WAS VERY TELLING IS
THE BIDEN SEGMENT AND FRIENDLY
JOE, LOVABLE JOE COMMITTING
GAFFES.
IT'S A BENIGN SLOB.
IT'S NOT A MEANINGFUL,
SUBSTANTIVE ISSUE.
>> Sean: REALLY?
DOES HE LOOK GOOD TO YOU?
HE LOOKS LOOK AT HIS WANT TO BE
THERE.
A THOUSAND YEARS SINCE HE LEFT
OFFICE.
>> ALL THAT TRUE BUT YOU HAVE
SUCH SITUATION WHERE HE GETS A
PASS FOR MAKING MISTAKE AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHEN HE MAKES A
MISTAKE, IT'S A LIE OR HE IS
STUPID.
THERE IS THAT MALICIOUSNESS, A
MALIGNANCY IN THE CRITICISM OF
THE PRESIDENT THAT DOES NOT
EXIST THE OTHER WAY AROUND AND I
THINK IT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE AND
VERY TELLING.
I CALLED MYSELF ROADKILL.
I'M IN THE MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD.
I GET IT FROM BOTH SIDES AND OUR
LATE GREAT BOSS ROGER AILES SAID
THE ONLY THING IN THE IN THE
MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD WAS ROADKILL.
I THINK SOMETIMES CONSERVATIVES
CAN BE DEFENSIVE.
THEY CAN BE ALMOST EMBARRASSED
ABOUT THEIR IDEOLOGY.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE AFRAID ABOUT
BOYCOTTS.
YOU ARE DIFFERENT.
ARE THE NEW WAVE OF
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
THEY'VE CHANGED THE PLAYING
FIELD.
FROM THE LEFT, I GET IT'S
PRETENTIOUS, SMUG, ARROGANT,
IT'S ARROGANT, THEY ARE SMARTER
THAN ME.
THEY THROW ADVERBS.
SLEAZY THIS OR THAT.
IT'S SO DISCOMFORTING TO ME AND
SO ANGERING TO ME THAT HERE,
THESE PEOPLE.
>> Sean: THE DIFFERENCE WITH
YOU GERALDO.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT DIFFERENCES
AND I SAY THIS IS A DEAR FRIEND
WHO RESPECTS, YOU'RE COMING UP
ON YOUR 50 YEARS.
YOU'VE HAD REMARKABLE WORK IN
WAR ZONES, WHAT YOU DID AT
WILLOWBROOK.
YOU MADE SERIOUS, SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES.
EVEN YOUR FIGHTS ON THE SET OF
THE GERALDO SHOW WERE AWESOME.
THE DIFFERENCE IS YOU LOVE THE
COUNTRY AND YOU WANT THE
PRESIDENT TO SUCCEED.
YOU MIGHT DISAGREE ON SOME
ISSUES.
BUT YOU WANT THE COUNTRY TO
PROSPER.
AND YOU SAY IT AND YOU STATED.
>> WE GET ONE PRESIDENT AT A
TIME.
WHEN HE SUCCEEDS, WE ALL SUCCEE
SUCCEED.
THERE'S A TIME FOR CAMPAIGNING.
THERE'S UP TIME FOR PARTISANSHIP
BUT THERE'S ALSO A TIME WHERE WE
ARE JUST AMERICANS.
THESE BITTER CALLS FOR BOYCOTTS
AND SO FORTH, AND DEBRA MESSING
ASKING FOR BLACKLIST AND OUTING
PEOPLE.
IT'S JOE McCARTHY.
IT'S THE REVERSE, THE MIRROR
IMAGE OF WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
1950s.
IT'S AS HATEFUL NOW AS IT WAS
THEN.
>> Sean: LAST WORD TO DAN.
>> I'VE JUST NEVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE IT.
I WORK OUT IN A RELATIVELY
CONSERVATIVE GYM AND THERE WAS A
GUY WITH AN OBAMA SHIRT ON AND
NOBODY SAID ANYTHING TO HIM.
YET A LIBERAL BY COME IN AND HE
SAID IS THAT THAT GUY FROM
FOX NEWS.
HE BETTER KEEP HIS HEAD DOWN,
TALKING ABOUT ME.
REALLY?
DOES TRUMP BOTHER YOU THAT MUCH,
YOU CAN'T WORK OUT IN THE GYM
WITHOUT SOME GUY CONFRONTING
YOU?
GET A GRIP, LEFTISTS.
>> Sean: I LOVE MY GYM RAT
FRIENDS.
I HAVE A LOT OF THEM.
YOU LIFT A LOT, MORE THAN I DO.
I HAVE ONE ADVANTAGE OVER YOU,
DAN BONGINO.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS.
>> YOU WOULD BE PROUD OF ME.
I LITERALLY JUST GOT OUT OF AN
MMA CLASS BEFORE I GOT ON THE
AIR.